the house committee investigating the
assault on the capitol launched the next
stage of its inquiry last night it
intends to question some of the highest
ranking figures from the trump
administration wishing is at the white
house with more on this story wiesha
good morning to you
good morning to you gail and good
morning to everybody the select
committee has announced subpoenas for
four close allies of former president
trump that includes former white house
chief of staff mark meadows mr trump's
former deputy chief of staff for
communications dan scavino kash patel
who is a former defense department
official and steve bannon a close
adviser to mr trump the panel believes
these four have relevant information
about the build up to the insurrection
and have asked that they produce
documents and appear at depositions in
october the committee chairman wrote to
meadows that the panel has quote
credible evidence of his involvement and
to bannon you are quoted as stating on
january 5th 2021 that all hell is going
to break loose tomorrow in a statement
the former president criticized what he
called harassment subpoenas and vowed to
fight them with executive privilege now
that is exactly what trump did to block
white house officials from testifying
during his impeachment trial but
congressman adam schiff who is a member
of the select committee says he is
hoping that this justice department
enforces the subpoenas and issues
criminal contempt charges if necessary
tony
all right thank you very much